so here on the reel you can see at the
top end a really beautiful sample of
research quality platinum platinum is a
very heavy metal and it is like silver
and gold it's a metal which does not
easily react with the oxygen in the air
so if you make jewelry out of it it
stays nice and shiny and looks nice
platinum and light gold is has a silvery
color with some people like you can make
alloys of silver and platinum gold and
platinum which will have different
colors of yellow depending on your taste
platinum is a very very precious metal
it's a very very high value not just for
jewelry but also for the production of
auto catalytic converters and other
chemical processes this wire here is
very very fine it's point zero one
millimeters in diameter and it is used
to study vapor phase and gas phase
chemistry's platinum is found in in a
number of places around the world for
example in South Africa but it's a very
small amount each ton of rock may have
as little of seven grams of platinum in
it so you have to break an awful lot of
rock to get this material in recent
years platinum has become very important
in catalysts in cars the catalytic
converters and so
more and more cars now or that all cars
now have platinum and have platinum in
their catalytic converters and if we're
going to go to hydrogen power in cars
using fuel cells these will probably
also need platinum in fact there's some
considerable question whether there is
enough platinum in the world to for all
the uses we want to put it to as one
gram there one gram of platinum